buckle up welcome to Hannity tonight
mass rage mass psychosis totally
consuming the modern Democratic
Socialist Party of course after
President Trump was vindicated by robert
muller and for the left it's like an
election night 2016 all over again
because for two and a half years
democrats along with their partners in
the media mob well they were pumping up
their base they got giddy they praise
their hero robert muller because they
were finally gonna get donald trump it's
like the eggs of polls showed that
donald trump was gonna lose they were
wrong and the facts of reality got in
the way because there never was
collusion no conspiracy no obstruction
from Trump and his campaign now
Democrats are deflated they're
downtrodden and they are hitting levels
of delusion with reckless fantasies
about impeachment and doing everything
they could possibly do to harass even
use the IRS against the sitting
president tonight we're exposing it
piece by piece and we're also gonna be
asking the most important unanswered
questions and by the way there are
hundreds of them but we're just giving
you the top ones like when did Robert
nullor
Muller know there was no collusion no
coordination why weren't we told why did
they hold that back and if they knew
there was no underlying crime all along
early on in the investigation why not
let the American people we the people
know to reveal to we the people that
this was all based on a series of false
narratives and phony allegations like
the steel dossier which why didn't he
investigate this which literally was
like a final nail drilled into the
coffin by Robert Muller
Byron York writes in the Washington
Examiner today quote in the wake of the
Muller report the question is not
whether the dossiers charges were
accurate but why were they so wrong even
our friend Bob Woodward a little late to
the party is acknowledging the problems
with Clinton's bought and paid for
Russian lies used in the election I
guess better late than never though take
a look early in building the
intelligence community assessment
Russian interference in an early draft
they actually put the dossier on page
two in kind of a breakout box I think it
was the CIA pushing this real
intelligence experts looked at this and
said no this is not intelligence this is
garbage and they took it out but in this
process the idea that they would include
something like that in one of the great
stellar intelligence assessments as
Muller also found out is highly
questionable needs to be investigated
highly questionable bob again we had an
ensemble team for over two years we've
been unpeeling the layers and after
layer after layer of the biggest abuse
of power corruption scandal in our
history and this ensemble cast on radio
and TV of my show we've been right all
along and now even the new york times
even they are finally coming to terms
with some dose of reality revealing in a
new piece that the dossier is now under
renewed scrutiny baby steps for them and
get this the media may have been more
wrong than we thought and according to
the time steals dossier may have been
all been part of a russian
disinformation campaign to begin with
Hillary's campaign she paid for it and
not to help Donald Trump but to set up
quote landmines and so chaos and discord
among the American electorate now the
hills John Solomon will join us in a few
moments to explain a lot more to you but
ask yourself when will the fake news
media mob when will they finally
apologize for their lies and conspiracy
theories when will they take
accountability when will they take
account for fueling collusion hysteria
breathless reporting day after day night
after night for the media facts were
only an afterthought any anonymous
source yes they believed like BuzzFeed's
bombshell about the president directing
Michael Cohen to lie which Muller's
report exposes totally false or NPR
being in bear
after light about John Jr Senate
testimony or McClatchy blatantly wrong
about Michael cones trip to Prague it
never happened or the Guardian reporting
a fake conspiracy about Muller and
Julian Assange 3 CNN employees forced to
resign after reporting an untrue Russia
related story about our friend the mooch
Anthony's Guerra Moochie or Brian Ross
leaving ABC after a fake news story
about Trump and Russia that actually
impacted negatively the stock market
there was fake hysteria about a Russian
spy in the White House or Bloomberg
forced to correct their story about
Trump and Deutsche Bank and the New York
Times had to walk back claims about Paul
Manafort
sharing polling data with a Russian
oligarch and don't forget the Washington
Post having to correct their story about
Russians hacking of Vermont utility
which wasn't true it was every second
every minute every hour of every day
fake story after fake story lie after
lie conspiracy after conspiracy theory
and after rather than take
responsibility for all of these failures
a epic fail the media is just seeking to
new lows doubling down on lies and
stupid just look at how an so-called
reporter over at NBC News literally
ambushed
Robert Muller as he's leaving Easter
services these people have no shame take
a look sir can you ask could I ask you a
couple of questions we testified before
Congress sir
no comment are you sure about that sir
well if if he were anybody but the
president would mr. Trump be indicted
sir sir why didn't you make a
recommendation to Congress one way the
others the Attorney General accurately
characterized your positions on
conspiracy and obstruction sir can we
like make churches out of bounds kids
out of bounds
the media's negligence their hysteria so
many unanswered question and as I've
said this is really only the first
chapter in what must be a reckoning for
the country if this country's to survive
it's that serious and literally we're
going to shine the light now on the 10
biggest and there are hundreds
unanswered questions like for example
one of the FBI first realized that the
dossier was bought and paid for by
Hillary Clinton on if they knew it why
didn't mother investigate that when
they're investigating the whole issue of
Russian interference
how much exculpatory evidence that they
have about George papadopolis Carter
page and did they hide that information
for the FISA Court and we have a
question especially for James Comey why
did James Comey say sign the first FISA
warm bulk of information on the warrant
of course was the dossier why did he
sign it which means he approved of it
zooming it's verified in October 2016
then tell Trump and Don Donald Trump
then president-elect in 2017 in January
Trump Tower
oh it's Alicia's but unverified he lied
in October of 16 or January is 2017 and
by the way why were Steele's anti-trump
bias has hit from the FISA Court like
telling them
Hillary bought in paid for it in big
bold letters why were US Intel officials
leaking details of the Russian probe
before ever corroborating anything to do
with collusion and by the way next
question did James Colby miss handle
classified information when leaking
memos of his private conversations with
the President and here's a big one okay
let's go to the Oh Bob
Whitehouse what did Susan Rice what did
Samantha Power's what it already Lynch
what did let me see Oh
Brennan and clapper what did they know
when did they know it what did Obama
know and when did he know it if as Paige
and struck her saying Loretta Lynch was
running the whole thing from inside the
Justice Department or by the way the in
the CIA or FBI did they engage or sign
off on surveillance against the Trump
team to spy on them before opening the
so called counterintelligence
investigation because in other words did
they bypass American laws about oh
abusing intelligence and using the
weapons of intelligence against the
American people and outsource that to
friendly allies and get information they
wouldn't otherwise get and by the way
maybe places like the UK to gather
evidence on the Trump campaign or maybe
Australia maybe Italy did the CIA try to
pressure the FBI into opening a Trump
collusion Pro before the election and by
the way we do need to know considering
was so important you know issues like
loan applications taxes and taxi
medallions
who else lied to Congress now we know
Andrew McCabe is being probed false
testimony but he also said remember no
dossier no FISA warrant by the way his
testimony contradicts that of Glenn
Simpson at fusion GPS somebody lied
somebody told the truth and it all
conflicts well Bruce or said but again
let's go back to Loretta Lynch what did
she know when did she know it James
clapper Brennan when did they know it
mark my words we are inching closer and
closer to justice there is no stopping
this abuse of power and corruption from
being exposed that I can promise you
tonight it's time for transparency and
accountability we cannot let this happen
in our country again my source is
telling me just buckle up it's all
coming soon it's time to declassify
those FISA applications rue Soares 302s
what we call our bucket of five we still
have the IG Horowitz he is expected
later this spring with his report on
FISA abuse the hueber report on leaking
abuse gang of eight material
let's see it all now Democrats want
transparency okay absolutely let's
expose the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in this country's
history the American people will be
shocked let's expose the new radical
extreme Democratic Party just still
hell-bent on spreading lies every second
hour of every day a public trial
non-stop witch-hunt against this
president when the Democrats aren't
fueling their unhinged Asteria Wow let
not your hearts be troubled because
their cohorts and the hate Trump media
mob they just pick up the slack take a
look if you know the main concern here
is that he's not going to be convicted
by the Senate Democrats maybe making a
bad political calculation there it's not
as if the Moller report was a dud this
is something that has a lot in it that
implicates the president in actual
crimes I still hope that in this day and
age Republicans will see the facts and
will be as appalled as the Democrats are
this report was completely exposing of
unfit impeachable behavior an innocent
man does not screech and and complain
some might ask why haven't you start why
haven't you opened an impeachment
inquiry or in fairness is that what
you're doing right now matter and to go
with the impeachment gets politicized so
you have a legal case that you believe
this happens and you should do it but
the politics dictate something else how
much is that going to influence this
decision these hands
deep down we know Democrats aren't
interested in the truth even Speaker
Pelosi downplaying impeachment writing
in a new letter that there are other
ways to hold the president accountable
she's scared to death knowing the
political ramifications this witch-hunt
continuing will mean for the Democratic
Party and her power and those sentiments
echoed by Democratic leaders in a call
earlier today that's not stopping the
radical base though of the new extreme
radical socialist democratic party like
collusion truther the biggest liar of
them all Adam the Cowardly shift
actually saying the molar report proved
him right well you can't make this stuff
up and I'll say it again by the way to
the congressman you are welcome on
this show anytime you want for the full
hour and I will give you three hours of
my radio show if you would like
let's see 615 stations and a big
audience so congressman you are welcome
anytime by the way that goes for the
rest of them they want to be a part of
it it anyway all right now as we
continue along anybody that wants to be
a part of this program we will expose
the lives of people like them and you
know what
how much hurting you're doing to the
American people in fact the real
polluter and all this is only one person
and we have evidence for by the way it's
comedic gold hears on tape collusion
with Russia to impact our elections and
she met with Trump and she brought him
one our Russian girl celebrity Olga boo
Sava who also known as a person with a
strange reputation Oh Olga boos ever
what's the nature of the compromise well
there were pictures of naked Trump and
so Putin was made aware of the
availability of the compromising
material yes of course thank you very
much we will be back in touch with you
through our staff to make arrangements
to obtain these materials for our
committee and and for the FBI and and I
appreciate your reaching out to us what
is the nature of the come from I picked
a naked thump did flat Amir see it
yeah but of course Vladimir see it oh we
want to impact the election you can't
make this stuff up then we have
congressman Devin Nunez by the way we've
warned about Russia and Putin hostile
actors on the world stage
Devin Nunez in 2014 warned the Obama
administration that's all happened on
their watch that this would happen in
2016 this is who they are this is what
they do and after 30 plus years of our
American government being hacked can we
please build the defenses to be
unhackable we should all all of us be
concerned about the integrity of our
elections and the fact that this
government has been hacked repeatedly
for decades by hostile regimes we need a
top-to-bottom killer defense procedures
again
these hackers that's why Hillary
Clinton's email server is a real threat
to our safety and security and we do
believe that that place was hacked by at
least four foreign six foreign entities
this was all weaponized in the press
inside the deep State to bludgeon Donald
Trump behind a curtain
we got lies so it's time to investigate
the investigators that means Hillary
Clinton and the fact that that
investigation was rigged then they tried
to rig a presidential election that and
they tried to undo a dually elected
president and the media was all the way
there let's stick to the facts and not
rush to judgment maybe the media can
self-reflect be introspective not jump
on to the next fake news story about the
president especially it's common sense
Americans wake up to their lies smears
and be searched man they can't act this
president with more endless
investigations anonymous sources now
thankfully the president's fighting back
just today the president filed a lawsuit
against the Democrats latest stunt now
they want to embolden the IRS release
his taxes explaining that the ploy has
no legitimate purpose not once that he
invoke executive privilege 1.5 million
documents even Don Magan the White House
Counsel 30 hours before Morel a Muller
you see what's going on they're out of
ideas there's no vision for the
betterment of we the people they've
synced to a psychotic low this is all
they think about and when they're not
pushing endless investigations it's
nonstop bar left socialism or
bludgeoning a 16 year old kid for
example look you want to see about
radical socialism look at comrade mayor
de Blasio of New York City announcing
plans this morning to ban quote
inefficient steel and glass skyscrapers
from New York and retrofit every big
building in New York take a look the
biggest source of emissions in New York
City is buildings we're putting clear
strong mandates the first of any major
city on the earth to say to building
owners you got to clean up your act
you got a retrofit you guys save energy
if you don't do it by 2030 there will be
serious fines we're going to ban the
classic glass and steel skyscrapers
which are incredibly in a fish
if someone wants to build one of those
things they can take a whole lot of
steps to make it energy efficient but
we're not gonna allow what we used to
see in the past no glass no steel how we
got to build those billion can't build
it with timber because that'd be cutting
down a tree and killing a tree no gas no
oil no cars no combustion engine no cows
no planes but everything's free they
don't they don't even meet that these
standards are so over the top Casio
Cortez has literally once every building
in America retrofitted Wow who's gonna
pay for that